ومع ترقب غربي للهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد
يبدو ان التوقعات الغربيه والتي وصفتها
كيب بالمبالغ فيها بحسب واشنطن بوست تضعيف
تحت ضغوط تتمثل في ان تلجا اوكرانيا حاله
ما فشلت في هجومها الى مفاوضات او على
الاقل تراجع الدعم العسكري الغربي السخي
لها منذ بدء الصراع بحسب الصحيفه فان
واشنطن وحلفائها تعتبر هذا الهجوم اختبارا
حاسما لمعرفه ما اذا كانت الاسلحه
والتدريب والذخيره التي ارسلت يمكن ان
تترجم الى مكاسب على الارض الهجوم بات
وشيكا ويمثل نقطه فارقه بالنسبه لكييف
وبينما تسعى كييف لاستعاده السيطره على
اراضي انضمتها موسكو فضلا طبعا عن اثبات
انها تستحق استمرار الدعم من الغرب يتبع
الرئيس بوتين وقوته جدولا زمنيا اطول وذلك
بعيدا عن الضغوط السياسيه المحليه رغم
معاناه بلاده من قيود الغرب الاقتصاديه
وايضا العسكريه ربما تكون اشكاليه سيد
الكرملين الاكثر الحاحا الان هي تصاعد
الخلافات بين باجنر والقاده العسكريين
الروس ما يهدد قدره موسكو على مواجهه
الهجوم المضاد على الارض مؤسس مجموعه
قال قد هدد بالاحرى بالانسحاب من خط
المواجهه في بخموت بسبب نقص الذخيره التي
لن تمكنه من مواصله القتال قبل ان يعود
ويؤكد انه تلقى وعودا بالحصول على ذخائر
واسلحه قريبا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات